[Music]
in thief trap news submitted by type
food so good
hi food Oh Thai food like I thought it
was take of food
it'd be so cool if this trap was like
you know that sticky paper that you keep
for rats or lizards yeah you're like run
and then they're like oh [ __ ] that's a
home alone trap it's very famous home
alone trap can we just talk about home
alone is it on Netflix now or something
like how come everyone's watching we
have to buy it like I we had a random
holiday all cuz it's Christmas Wow pop
him in a man is taking revenge on
package thieves with a trap that sets
off 12-gauge shotgun blanks why do they
gotta be blanks that's a bladder empty
yeah that's awesome
mm-hmm so this man his name is Doreen
from Tacoma dreamed the dream like that
that's a good pick-up line Thanks yes so
he created this trap using a cardboard
box wooden structure and 12-gauge
shotgun blanks and pretty much he
created this because he got tired of
people stealing his expensive Jeep parts
people does he have coming over jack and
stuff it's that bad out there I guess in
his neighborhood in our house [ __ ]
holiday season it's our house by the way
in our house the holiday season [ __ ]
hate those people do what they do you
just hate those people because this
isn't just stolen yeah right when I
moved in I moved in during the holiday
season they haven't happens in uh lately
no but I know around the holiday season
they will they should just take it
though because there's so many stairs to
climb
you're gonna mean like dessert make it
all the way to the top like just take it
bro like you deserve it so now I know
you live somewhere with lot of stairs
okay like narrowed it
it's Steve stealing my packages all
right so I'm gonna show you this
compilation video of all the thieves
that got startled by this this box fun
compilation
does he have the Benny Hill song so
pretty much like once you move this box
that's when the shotgun blinks so just
how is this showing with the shotgun
blanks yeah oh so these are these are uh
peek cake box boxes that he left out
yeah exactly
burglary attempts though yeah real
burglars huh he's saying that it got to
a point where he had to put like a
notice on it so he doesn't get sued or
anything it's like warning this package
is armed also if you enter this area
you're being filmed like how can you get
sued for someone [ __ ] trespassing onto
your property and trying to steal on
your [ __ ] baby you sued you get sued in
your own home if someone tries to rob
you and like punching you out and you
punch back they can see you if your kid
slips in the bathtub they can sue you
gotta be careful [ __ ] thief oh yeah
fancy loud maybe it doesn't read the the
frequency doesn't come in the camera
she's at the door was kind of open like
you're just open foot here's a note you
can't read he's reading the note
why is he stilled investigation oh my
gosh it hell yeah he's still
investigating what a dumbass
Jesus that's recently hella thieves like
seven days once a different Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
awesome yeah I can't believe it that's
after his jeep parts have been stolen
too
yeah people keep coming back that's us
it's all different people to like
they're not they don't seem like they're
old friends yeah it's like a girl guys
why tell Nikki she's like she's like I
wonder how someone else on my own oh man
yeah I like being in an apartment
created products that were you like
hanging on your door and it has like a
secret like a code that the delivery guy
can get so then they can enter the code
for your package in and then ceiling
back up so they don't get stolen I saw
like a box it was like I'd just like a
wooden box where it has a scanning code
thing the delivery I just scanned some
barcode on your box and then it unlocks
laying there and you lock it yeah but
see what happens for people like myself
who orders wards big boxes it was like a
sizable [ __ ] yeah but that's a big
box it's the size of a pen like a big
thing dude it's like a size of a bench
yeah yes I get my sword stolen I ain't
guy had a sword for Halloween I should I
don't know why but a real sorceress
Halloween and then I stored it in my
locker and someone broke into my locker
and stole my spell all do you yeah maybe
it was just a sword yeah what couple
stupid
that's when times were awesome that's so
true sometimes I see blonde yeah stole
my sword
no big died how did he make this thing
so he made it I want to learn how to
make it
mm-hmm well you don't need to because he
created his own product or you can buy
yeah it's called the blank box you
should do it set it up slippery stairs -
yeah I love let's always in my head all
cartoon noises are always
I should I'm gonna do that because I'm
gonna get the doorbell camera thing and
then I can record the whole thing it'll
be great oh you don't have a camera oh
then you put it up on your YouTube yeah
I'll be great and please use the
painting yep any hope you got a great
footage of this dream he even created
these t-shirts touch my package unless
you're a hot girl that's what should say
legally yes this is the blank box and
I'm gonna show you guys a clip of him
explaining how it works so you can buy
either a single or a double where you
could put like either one or two I'll
put like 500 yes I want to make it so
easy for them to try to scale so that
you put in planks board from putting
reals then you kill them I'm sure you
can mod it I'm sure you can bought it
somehow I don't think it projectiles no
I want beans and shell though it's like
there's a million little babies inside a
name go yeah yeah yeah but I don't think
I don't think this actually has a
mechanism for shooting didn't you see
this bar slip I'll show you I'll show
you what if it's the paint from the anti
shoplifting [ __ ] that's just stuck on
their face for like three weeks I would
love that
oh I would [ __ ] love that was it use
pull chain and then you fall on them and
then a bunch of chicken feathers that is
glue and chicken that always used to
bust me out I'm gonna put this on your
front porch driveway wherever you're
having an issue gonna take your blank
box and box here slide it right over top
and you're gonna take your lobster claw
and hook it around this is the double
each eye hole oh yeah this is blank in
your blanks we have to provide my own
ammo hold it up I don't know if you can
get Blake stop Hornet oh yeah I'm sorry
it's not gonna be even close to his
allows gonna be in real life so
lives in this with a bang shall we oh
[ __ ] we could hear it I want that [ __ ]
would be scary especially because he's
already his heart is probably already
racing like trying to steal something I
would play a Clint Eastwood sound bite
as well like I heard you [ __ ] I
said [ __ ] like that
like something from that movie gran
torino are using pizza home Alone's
gonna be Merry Christmas you filthy oh
that would have been great with a little
shopping and women when it counted three
years I'm like to get you ugly yellow
no-good keys off my property
no I mean the movie there was a fake
movie Oh angels with filthy souls or
some [ __ ] yeah cuz I'm like oh I watch
that it's called in the movie here
whatever man I'm totally getting this I
know what I want for Christmas burger
family you are at least today you are
Amazonas is really dope thing we're in
supermarkets they have Amazon lockers so
if you are someone that unfortunately
gets your [ __ ] still a long time I don't
work for Amazon by the way but I saw
this I thought was really really cool
is it illegal to booby-trap your house
boo trap your trap I don't know maybe
here in California but maybe not true
probably well there's a professional
company that booby traps your house for
like millionaires and billionaires and
it's [ __ ] sick like I guess it's not
illegal oh well well maybe they have
enough of a millionaire's a billion you
might have enough lawyers and stuff but
it's it gets so elaborate to the point
where you they install machine guns in
your [ __ ] like wall yeah or like shop
yeah they're like shotguns interesting
killer so like if people are entering
your home through your phone like
remotely you could kill that oh yeah
they're like in your house you can just
and then boom it just shoots through the
[ __ ] wall and all that [ __ ] yeah how
many people actually want it to walk in
a room full of lasers oh hell yeah
you mean looking see you get those
eyebrows long I know you like mission
impossible when you're like this
like I wish that I can escape room type
of thing there is there is it's right
here in wandering Park this an escape
room it's lasers yeah dude it's called
the vault where you see break out of a
bank and it's all lasers and [ __ ] 20:02
like it was like a mirror maze and then
next to it was like this laser means no
but what did you get the laser in your
eyes what I mean it's not gonna hurt you
you just like the light no no I know
right so now what do you want to do in
there though I want to be all in black
like a [ __ ] cat bird okay that's it
and then just kind of like get get a
treasure and then get out and see if I
can do it what you need to do is go to a
bondage party with lasers Kevin Zenith
and Sean Connery yeah that one I'm a
trap man dog I remember I would pretend
to be I would go under my brother's crib
yes she was that scene was hot with her
on your boat scrap to oceans and that
means our oceans 12 where that damn the
lasers what there's a Ocean's eleven sir
ocean Culver that dude danced through
the lasers it was dope as [ __ ] oh we had
the French guys yeah but that was
[ __ ] like how would he do that
you zoom like back flips through it like
I hate that [ __ ] trans man Zeta made it
look real real sexy I feel like that
that booby trap company is like the
perfect company for Joe yeah it sounds
like a company that's willing to help
millionaires and billionaires hunt
humans it was a security company for the
rich and famous it was a documentary and
on that you guys I don't know they
needed to but then they steal from Kim
Kardashian and we can't have that in
this world
[ __ ] yeah we got to protect them for
like super rich serial killers like I
need you to build me this thing that
murders people slowly I know cuz they
already like if you're a billionaire
already to get your rocks off you just
you you hunt humans in the open field
your jollies yeah do I guess what do
what sit what is your culture say I
don't even know what that means your do
you have a fiesta
your daddy here Fiesta on there we go
you know they hunt human beings like
hostile right like you torture human
beings for fun wasn't it the purge that
de some [ __ ] like that but that's not
just rich people though it's a
free-for-all
safest during the purge you know the
purge part where the grandpa is you guys
see the [ __ ] you don't watch anyway
but the granite wall yeah you're not in
watching where he sacrificed themselves
and then he went to a white person's
house and they killed him oh I heard
about like serial killers who pick up
hookers and literally dropped mouths in
the woods and just give him a head start
so he can pump them down ah see I like
the purge it's awesome I think it's a
good idea if I'm not going that gets
killed it's the people I love don't get
killed all this [ __ ] you talk online you
have a fan base dude you don't have
enough stairs
[Laughter]